hey guys why do action scenes suck
see all these dumb trailers with these
dumb action shots and you were like oh
my god this movie's gonna suck even
though that shots cool well generally
that's probably why the action scenes
suck is cuz they're pointless they are
there just for spectacle and really add
nothing to the characters or expand the
story many filmmakers forget that even
though there see might have action in it
it still needs to be a cohesive scene
like for example a dialogue scene
between a couple having a fight and
generally the worst crime of them all is
that the action isn't even that good
it's all obscured by bad camera work and
weird choreography and quick edits that
are hard to follow so what makes a good
action scene let's start at the top
first up good action scenes tend to show
the action rather than imply it now
there's a reason for implying things but
we'll get to that later but for the most
part we're talking about actually
showing it with a wider shot that let
you see what's occurring a longer
movement that helps add to the energy
the scene without obscuring it clear
sense of space because it's important to
understand why a character is making
their decisions whether it's from a
dialog standpoint where they're going
through an emotional moment or an action
standpoint where they're trying to
survive and not get killed or having
checked the action and the reaction in
the same shot you need to show the
geometry in the space of what they're in
to understand why they are making
decisions or why they are in danger now
this is expensive it requires a lot of
coordination having a lot of people on
the shot having effects going off timed
up with actions it's very very difficult
to film these kind of scenes and that's
actually why you don't see them very
often in fact what many filmmakers tend
to do to save money is they imply the
action rather than showing it so what is
implying action mean we're talking
close-ups we're talking obscuring the
movement and hiding what's happening
we're talking about shaky angles that
prevent you from understanding the
movement in the shot now all this
conveys what's happening you understand
in your head there's a fight happening
or somebody's trying to hurt another
person but you're not seeing the how and
the why and you're not seeing the
movement that's dictating why they're
doing what they're doing and the
decisions are making in that fight it's
certainly not as entertaining as this
because we're actually seeing the action
and the reaction happening in the same
shot it's more believable it's more
impressive Bruce you got to work with me
this allows us to see how the characters
are thinking what they're doing how
they're moving you get everything in one
nice package I'm sorry let's get on the
flip side here go now implying action
while generally use to make things less
expensive can be used to some really
nice dramatic effect an example of
implied action being really useful and
dramatic is in Saving Private Ryan when
Tom Hanks his soldier hits the beach for
the first time and he's surrounded by
the chaos and the violence of warfare we
enter the sequence where the shutter
speed drops and things get a little
blurry err and we cut from moment to
moment out of context thankfully it's a
very simple type of movement they're
going straight from the water all the
way up to the top of the hill and that's
it and it all works to put us in the
mindset of a soldier hitting the d-day
beaches for the very first time a lot of
people forget that an action scene is
still a scene first and foremost you
have spectacle as your action and you
have your character development as your
actual scene and you want to blend those
into an action scene generally speaking
action scenes tend to just convey that
one person wants to kill another person
or they simply don't want to die and are
trying to survive so talking about
emotions in action scene is also very
important King Kong why are the
dinosaurs bouncing around nobody really
knows I don't think anyone's ever
figured that one out it Resident Evil
movies every single sing a little bit of
them just there's no reef we did that
just you're just stop playing the
footage appear realistically the best
scenes any kind of scene in movie tells
some sort of emotional arc for the
character and reveals and unveils
various elements of the plot that
continues this forward momentum that
makes you want to watch more and doing
this in an action scene is just as
important as any other senior Moodle so
a great example of a fight scene that is
more than just a fight for survival is
the last fight scene in the matrix now
in the same neo is up against agent
Smith and it appears they are fighting
for survival I mean Agent Smith is
trying to kill neo in an onslaught of
fists and bullets but there's another
layer to the scene neo has been told
throughout this entire story that he is
a hero he is going to save mankind
and he's starting to question that he's
going to discover by the end of the
scene whether or not he is the hero the
prophesized hero that is going to save
humanity from the machines so there's
this emotional undercurrent of neo
needing to prove himself and find this
confidence and discover this element
about him on top of just simply
surviving and that's what makes it a
great action scene it's more than just a
fight we're actually getting an
emotional story and we're getting a
character of Star Wars has some of the
best action scenes ever because every
single one of them is incredibly
emotional every single lightsaber fight
is not to show you how how far down they
can limbo over this other guys swing and
lightsaber and so every single
lightsaber fight is literally them just
trying to get a grip on their emotions a
little like it's incredible it's like
prequels suck just look at this clip of
how bad they're missing so all this talk
about character and emotion might make
it seem like spectacle it is it
important but it is it's extremely
important it's just as important as
everything else but it must go hand in
hand with character development and
story now good action has spectacle and
spectacle is visually entertaining
without an emotional connection to our
characters we don't care this is
actually a challenge a lot of natural
disaster films face San Andreas it for
example they show us cities getting torn
apart in giant volcanoes exploding and
wiping out chunks of the earth it's
tricky to make people care now if you
look at Independence Day you'll notice
that in these scenes of large
destruction these scenes of great
spectacle we actually have characters
involved that we've grown to love their
characters that we are watching and we
are invested in their survival and they
put these characters in these moments so
that we feel the tension if the
characters have no reason to be involved
in the action and they're not
emotionally attached to the outcome well
then they don't have any reason to be
there they aren't going to learn or grow
from it and it's kind of a waste of that
characters time and of course by
extension kind of a waste of our time
so I'll spectacle is great that
spectacle needs to be attached it needs
to be grounded it needs to matter it
needs to have an emotion behind it and
when those two things pair together as
they do so rarely in films that's when
you get great action scenes so yeah why
do action scenes suck well they're hard
to do you need to have an incredible
team working on set you need to have the
budget and funding behind it to pull it
off
takes patience practice and persistence
to do good action from a technical
standpoint they're incredible feats of
coordination being captured on film on
top of that there's a whole layer of
storytelling and kinetic movement that
is such a different realm from the
technical proficiency of shooting a film
that bring the two together doesn't
always happen that often so next time
you go to the movies you see an action
scene that's clear and you know what's
going on and it feels visceral and you
care about the characters and what they
are doing and there's layers to the
story savor that moment hopefully this
video has created a bit of an
appreciation for what it takes to pull
off that kind of an action scene and you
can come out of the film enjoying it
even more than you originally would have
we are certainly constantly trying to
figure this stuff out for ourselves as
filmmakers leave a comment below
consider subscribing see you later all
right bye guys
why are you doing that